digamos que yo tengo una compañía dentro
del país eeuu aquí dibujo mi compañía la
voy a poner aquí esta es mi compañía y
tiene unas chimeneas por acá como las
grandes fábricas y sale humo ahí está el
humo y bueno es una compañía que genera
un millón de dólares un millón de
dólares pre impuestos esto de aquí es
pre impuestos y el país como puedes ver
es eeuu
digamos que en el tiempo que yo hago
esas ganancias la tasa de impuesto
corporativo es del 35 por ciento
entonces la tasa es de 35 por ciento en
impuestos 35 por ciento tasa de
impuestos ahora pensemos en la cantidad
de impuestos que yo estaría pagando 35
de ese millón sería entonces
esencialmente yo pagaría 350 mil 350 mil
dólares en impuestos así que me queda de
ganancia 650 1600
50000 en ganancias ahora lo que quiero
pensar digamos que mi compañía se pone
creativa con respecto a una manera de
ahorrar en impuestos y entonces se da
cuenta que hay una isla no muy lejana
del país en la costa este bueno de hecho
hay varias pero aquí está esta isla esta
isla con sustantivamente una tasa de
impuestos menor digamos que tiene una
tasa de impuesto corporativo del 5% 5%
en tasa de impuestos ahora una pregunta
cómo puede esta compañía que está
físicamente dentro del país beneficiarse
de la tasa de impuestos que sucede en
esta isla como puede pasar eso bueno
típicamente lo que se hace es crear otro
subsidiario controlado por esta compañía
pero que está en esta isla aquí lo voy a
poner aquí está entonces lo que se le
hará es darle propiedad intelectual
propiedad intelectual marcas patentes y
cosas por el estilo entonces se le dan
aquí lo voy a poner
propiedad intelectual ahora quiero dejar
una cosa clara esto estoy aquí le
pertenece voy a dibujar un camino esto
le pertenece y es controlado por esta
compañía que está dentro del país dentro
de eeuu así que lo que dirán es bueno
miren ya no tenemos esta ganancia para
impuestos de un millón de dólares porque
ahora tenemos licencia licencia de esta
propiedad intelectual de marcas derecho
de autor patentes etcétera entonces
deben pagarle a esta entidad acá una
cierta cantidad de dinero entonces
digamos que le van a pagar 800 mil
dólares ajá ahora en teoría debe ver una
manera justa para decidir la tasa para
la propiedad intelectual pero comúnmente
esa propiedad intelectual es única lo
cual hace difícil ponerle una tasa en el
mercado y entonces la compañía misma lo
decide ellos mismos dicen cuánto van a
pagarle así que entremos a esa realidad
en lugar de esta de aquí
la compañía antes tenía ganancias de un
millón pre impuestos pero ahora están
pagando 800 mil a esta entidad en la
isla así que de ese millón tenemos 800
mil que van directos a la costa este
así que aquí van 800 mil 800 mil a la
costa este lo cual hace que la verdadera
ganancia pre impuestos basada en este
plan pagando a éste subsidiario en la
costa por el uso de la propiedad
intelectual
la compañía ahora tiene 200 mil en
ganancia pre impuestos esto era antes de
tener la licencia y ahora esto es
después de la licencia 200 mil es el
nuevo número pre impuestos así que esto
de aquí ya no ahora 200 mil es el nuevo
número pre impuestos esto es entre
impuestos entonces solamente se debe
pagar 35 por ciento de los 200 mil en
lugar de pagar los 350 mil que antes se
pagaban así que ahora ya no se paga esto
esto adiós esto ya no ahora solamente se
pagarán 70 mil 70 mil en impuestos 70
mil en impuestos
y por lo tanto esta compañía que está
dentro de dentro de eeuu mostraría una
ganancia de 200 mil
70.000 así que esto ya no ahora serían
130 mil dólares en ganancia neta en
ganancia neta y post impuestos claro y a
este digamos que esté subsidiario tiene
un bajo costo supongamos pero
esencialmente todo esto sería ganancia
ignoraremos por simplicidad que hay
algunos gastos por ahí así que tenemos
800 mil en su ganancia pre impuestos y
pagaría 5% de ello en impuestos y 5% de
800.000 es 40.000 dólares que pagarán
impuestos entonces lo voy a poner aquí
son 5% de 800 mil son 40 mil dólares que
pagarían impuestos al gobierno de esa
isla y entonces se quedará con 760 mil
la diferencia son 760 mil en ganancia
neta esto es la ganancia neta entonces
puedes tú observar aquí que la compañía
ahorro sustancialmente en impuestos
pago 70.000 en eeuu y pago 40.000 fuera
de y eso da un total de 110 mil dólares
versus los 350 que hubiera pagado si
estuviera en base solamente eeuu
entonces quizás tú digas wow eso es
genial y por qué sólo hacer esa
transferencia de 800 mil porque no hacer
una transferencia del millón completo
bueno pues deben un balance claramente y
obviamente si hubiera un mercado para
esta propiedad intelectual si existen
este tipo de propiedad intelectual o si
tiene una licencia esto dicta la
cantidad de 800 mil y justamente aquí
viene lo interesante quizás tú tengas
ganancia en efectivo esta ganancia en
efectivo pero esta ganancia no la podrás
ingresar a eeuu sin pagar impuestos por
ello y ahí está ese es el mero punto la
razón por la que hacemos impuestos esa
es es para justamente para que las
compañías no pueden hacer esto día y
noche
esencialmente yo hablo de transferir
ganancias fuera del
y luego regresarlas dentro del país y
para no permitir que esto suceda tara
tenemos los siguientes impuestos
impuestos la repatriación de fondos
lleva a impuestos y claro que depende de
los precios de las transferencias y de
todo eso y bueno aquí en este vídeo
vimos un ejemplo para evadir impuestos
para el pago de impuestos y hay otras
maneras existen otras tal que se le
pueda dar la vuelta al pago de impuestos
y bueno hablaré de eso en otros vídeos
más adelante